bonsoir
le mauvais temps d'abord cela tourne à
la catastrophe en italie depuis ce matin
les pluies torrentielles qui se sont
abattues sur le nord du pays ont déjà
fait 11 morts et quatre disparus
toutes les victimes sont mortes noyées
ou ensevelies sous les décombres de leur
maison la plupart des routes et les
autoroutes dont la région de gênes et de
turin sont coupées la circulation est
très difficile évidemment d'autant plus
que les ponts s'écroule
la ville d'aoste 30000 habitants et
isolés par les eaux depuis ce matin les
opérations de sauvetage sont
particulièrement difficiles car la pluie
continue à tomber sur tout le nord de
l'italie
il s'agit là de l'une des plus grave
inondation qu'ait connu l'italie au
cours des 20 dernières années
autre conséquence de ce mauvais temps la
ligne de chemin de fer du simplon entre
la suisse et l'italie a été coupée le
tunnel du mont blanc est fermé lui
depuis ce matin un poids lourds toujours
en raison des inondations
et puis pour demain la météo n'est pas
très optimiste des nuages et de la pluie
de la manche aux pyrénées avec de la
brume le matin dans le courant de
l'après midi ces pluies vont s'étendre
des ardennes à la méditerranée les
averses sont aussi prévus sur l'ouest
les vents de sud à sud ouest vont se
renforcer notamment sur les côtes et
dans la vallée du rhône
les autres grands titres de l'actualité
maintenant avec tout d'abord l'espagne
et cet attentat qui a coûté la vie au
président de l'assemblée provinciale de
biscaye ainsi qu'à deux autres personnes
qui l'accompagnaient
un quatrième blessé a été transporté
dans un hôpital dans un état grave
monsieur hinse état et ses amis venaient
juste de quitter le fronton de guernica
où il venait de jouer comme tous les
samedis à la pelote basque
lorsque leur voiture a été mitraillé par
un commando en fin de matinée pour
l'instant ce triple assassinat n'a pas
été revendiqué mais il faut rappeler
qu'il survient au lendemain de l'annoncé
par les extrémistes de letea
l'organisation autonomistes basques de
continuer la lutte armée
et puis un attentat qui coïncide aussi
avec le début à madrid des négociations
entre le gouvernement et les partis
d'opposition négociations qualifiées par
certains d'historique
benoît alba de madrid
la nouvelle de l'attentât a surpris tous
les leaders politiques espagnols au
cours de la réunion qu'ils avaient
depuis ce matin avec le premier ministre
adolfo suarez vers 2h30 à l'annonce du
meurtre du président de la députation de
biscaye les travaux de ce sommet ont été
suspendus le temps que les chefs des
délégations de toutes les familles
politiques se rassemblent pour condamner
l'attentât
et pour lancer un appel demandant à tous
les espagnols de conserver leur
confiance envers la démocratie tous
depuis le parti communiste jusqu'en et
aux franquistes sauf les représentants
de la minorité parlementaire basque que
nous avons vus quitter précipitamment le
palais de la moncloa la résidence du
chef de gouvernement à cette nouvelle
ce qui s'est passé cet après midi à
guernica est très grave d'abord parce
que ce meurtre fait passer au second
plan des préoccupations espagnole cette
réunion de tous les horizons politiques
du pays au cours de laquelle adolfo
suarez souhaitait conclure un pacte avec
l'opposition parlementaire et se mettre
d'accord avec elle sur un certain nombre
d'options clé le fait de pouvoir
rassembler les hommes que nous avons vu
ce matin autour de la même table passe
est ici pour un événement historique de
nature à faciliter la recherche des
solutions aux problèmes que la jeune
démocratie espagnole traverse
actuellement très grave ensuite parce
que le geste des terroristes intervient
à quelques jours seulement du vote que
les cortès doivent émettre sur un projet
d' amnistie élaboré par la gauche et le
parti gouvernemental
un projet qui n'est pas vue d'un très
bon oeil notamment par certains
militaires très grave enfin car après le
rétablissement de la généralité de
catalogne le gouvernement d'adolphe au
soir et c'est les parlementaires basque
avait entamé depuis deux semaines des
négociations en vue d'aboutir au
rétablissement d'un statut d'autonomie
pour le pays basque l'aministie si large
soit elle et l'autonomie ne nous
suffisent pas avait déclaré hier le
théâtre dans une communication
téléphonique à une station de radio de
bilbao letea continuera la lutte armée
jusqu'à ce que le gouvernement veuille
réellement changer les choses
cela signifie dans l'esprit de ses
militants jusqu'à la création d'un état
basque indépendant
et puis toujours à propos du pays basque
le militant séparatiste
à pala tj placé sous contrôle judiciaire
depuis sa libération le 6 septembre
dernier et qui devait se présenter
chaque mardi et chaque vendredi devant
les policiers de marseille ap hm là
teddy a disparu d'après ses avocats
cette absence n'aurait pas un caractère
définitif après dix jours de silence les
ravisseurs de monsieur schleyer ont
transmis ce matin à deux journaux
français libération et françois et à une
agence de presse suisse une lettre du
patron des patrons ouest allemand et une
photo couleur qui ont été identifiées
authentifié même par les services de
sécurité ouest allemand dans cette
lettre de trois feuillets adressées à
son épouse monsieur schleier demande au
gouvernement fédéral de se décider
rapidement
il explique également qu'il va bien
physiquement une nouvelle réunion de
l'état major de crise s'est produite cet
après midi à bonn pour étudier les
derniers développements de cette affaire
schleyer la conférence de belgrade sur
la détente entre l'est et l'ouest
fin de la première semaine de travaux
les 35 représentants des états
signataires des accords d'helsinki ont
pris la parole les uns après les autres
ces jours derniers la semaine prochaine
tous ces diplomates examineront à la
loupe les engagements qui avaient été
pris il ya plus de deux ans helsinki et
les résultats qui ont été obtenus depuis
a remarqué quand même qu'à belgrade les
américains en ce qui concerne les droits
de l'homme par exemple ont mis leurs
critiques quelque peu sous l'éteignoir
ce qui n'a pas été du tout le cas pour
les européens et pour les français en
particulier
et cela même si le représentant de la
france monsieur bettencourt pense qu'il
ne devrait pas y avoir d'affrontements
très important avril à belgrade
je ne crois pas qu'il fallait s'attendre
à des confrontations
tous les discours que nous avons
entendus jusqu'à présent tente à prouver
que de part et d'autre on souhaite
aborder les problèmes avec sérieux mais
sans esprit vindicatif et sans vouloir
se faire la guerre les 11
c'est donc dans un climat de respect
réciproque la conférence et commence
c'est à dire que personne n'étant plus
sur l'accusé
personne n'est tombé sur les cuisses
et sur ce problème des droits de l'homme
alors quelle est la position de la
france la position de la france c'est de
dire les choses comme elles les sens et
comme elles sont c'est à dire qu'il
s'agit pas de faire de la polémique et
parieurs il s'agit pas non plus de
laisser passer les événements comme
s'ils n'existaient pas par conséquent un
certain nombre de choses seront dit avec
fermeté avec netteté mais sans
agressivité et la détente alors est ce
qu'elle se porte mieux est ce que je
porte plus mal de cadres moi je crois
qu'elle se porte mieux
oui peut-être que je suis optimiste mais
quand je pense n'est ce pas calcine qui
finalement 25 nations signé se sont
engagés ont exprimé une volonté
je pense que quoi qu'il advienne cette
volonté est en marche elle continuera de
s'exprimer l'opinion publique est alerté
dans le monde entier on attend un
affermissement de la détente par
conséquent je crois que nous sommes sur
un chemin beer c'est à dire que le
risque de l'apocalypse nucléaire parce
que c'est en fait tout de même de ça
qu'il s'agit
mais plus loin à votre avis qu'avant il
suffit pas mais moi je n'y crois pas je
ne veux pas y croire c'est plutôt ça qui
veut dire parce que ne s'est jamais
montré les efforts ici vont dans ce sens
ce n'est pas chacun essaie de faire un
pas en avant à verdon jacques chaban
delmas qui est revenu ce matin de son
bref voyage privé en israël a répété
qu'il n'avait pas été chargé d'aucune
mission
l'ancien premier ministre a ajouté
malgré tout qu'il allait rendre compte
au gouvernement français de ses
entretiens avec monsieur beghi à propos
du proche orient je vous convient d'ores
et déjà à ne pas manquer une édition
spéciale de notre magazine question de
temps qui sera diffusée mercredi
prochain à 20h30 sur antenne 2 le proche
orient
aujourd'hui avec des reportages de nos
envoyés spéciaux en israël en egypte et
aux etats-unis mercredi 20h30 sur
antenne
en grande bretagne une manifestation pas
tout à fait comme les autres aujourd'hui
dans les ruches de la banlieue de
manchester pas moins de 3000 bobbies
les policiers britanniques avaient pris
position pour protéger un seul
manifestant
celui qui porte drapeaux ici cet homme
c'est martin webster le leader du front
national un parti raciste d'extrême
droite et policiers préféré prendre
leurs précautions après les violentes
émeutes entre extrémistes de droite et
de gauche qui ont eu lieu cette année à
birmingham et dans la banlieue de
londres
finalement il n'y a pas eu de graves
incidents mais une belle bousculade
quand même car les contre manifestants
de gauche étaient là l'escort des
bobbies de monsieur webster a quand même
coûté près de 250 mille livres à la
ville de manchester retour à l'actualité
en france maintenant avec à lyon la
première rencontre nationale du
troisième âge
plusieurs milliers de personnes
assistent aujourd'hui et demain à cette
manifestation qui va se terminer par un
déjeuner de plus de cinq mille couverts
et surtout par un discours demain
après-midi discours important de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
la politique c'était avant tout
aujourd'hui les explications bis de
françois mitterrand à rtl il a
pratiquement répété ce qu'il avait dit
hier soir c'est à dire pas de changement
de cap pour le parti socialiste pas de
polémique avec georges marchais mais le
ton était quand même plus vifs
aujourd'hui tout le monde nous tirent
dessus a dit françois mitterrand il faut
éviter que le pays ne tombe dans une
sorte de guerre civile larvée
aujourd'hui et demain se réunit à paris
le comité directeur du parti socialiste
deux textes ont été proposés dès ce
matin au comité directeur le premier
texte
lehmann du crs qui demande que la
convention du 5 novembre se transforme
en congrès extraordinaire afin de
reprendre la négociation sur la
réactualisation du programme commun le
deuxième texte vient de la majorité du
parti socialiste dans ce texte on doit
reparler des nationalisations fin du
comité directeur demain en fin de
matinée deuxième réunion importante du
week end le congrès extraordinaire du
cds à lyon le centre des démocrates
sociaux
jacques barreau comme jacques chirac
hier soir a lancé un appel en direction
des français déçus par l'alliance de la
gauche
on sait que jacques barrot va quitter le
secrétariat général du cds on sait aussi
que monsieur andré diligent devrait le
remplacer
mais bernard stasi a quand même provoqué
un mini coup de théâtre aujourd'hui à
lyon nancy copains à lyon vous avez
assisté aux travaux de ce congrès du cds
je pense que vous êtes en ligne
on avait même dit qu'il pourrait être
candidat à la présidence les premiers
mots qu'il a prononcés ont provoqué une
assez vive surprise
chers amis je voudrais simplement très
rapidement vous donner quelques
explications
dans un souci de clarté et dans un souci
de franchise j'ai refusé d'être candidat
à la présidence ou secrétariat général
du centre des démocrates sociaux
cet événement montre bien l'ambiance
d'un congrès qui est démarqué au moins
en apparence par des problèmes de
personnes et par des problèmes de statut
ces querelles pourrait paraître bien
mineur mais elles traduisent le
semble-t-il un malaise assez profond du
centre des démocrates sociaux
ce malaise est au fond le fait que
ce mouvement a bien du mal à se définir
lui-même et comme on dit à la recherche
de son identité
d'une part les craquements qui viennent
de se produire dans l'opposition ont
réveillé bien des espoirs on serait
tenté de dire bien des nostalgies de la
tendance qui se situe la plus à gauche
d'autre part le cds après avoir collé au
giscardisme pendant plusieurs années au
point parfois de donner l'impression de
se fondant lui est maintenant très
sensible très susceptible et se méfie de
tout ce qui pourrait ressembler à des
tentatives d'absorption le paysage
politique dit on est en train de changer
les centristes le 10 et le pense aussi
une raison de plus pour eux de
s'interroger comme ils se sont souvent
interrogé dans le passé mais on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui ils le font
avec beaucoup plus de passion attentats
au domicile de monsieur alain peyrefitte
le ministre de la justice la nuit
dernière une bombe a explosé devant la
porte de l'immeuble du garde des sceaux
il n'y a pas de blessé cet attentat a
été revendiqué par le noyau armée pour
l'autonomie populaire toujours plus gros
toujours plus fort lancement à saint
nazaire ce matin du frère jumeau du bâti
luce et du bella mia des pétroliers
géants de 500 de 50 mille tonnes 414 m
de long équipé avec un hôtel des
restaurants une piscine une salle de
sport et un cinéma une véritable ville
flottante
sarah
ce n'était ni la voix du pétrolier ni la
voix du commandant de bord mais
simplement un petit ennui avec la nounou
magnétophone
je pense que vous avez quand même a pu
apprécier les 414 m 2,7 ce gigantesque
pétroliers ça devient une habitude
depuis quelques semaines les fanas de la
bécane j'entends les motards qui tourne
normalement à rungis tous les vendredis
et les samedis sont venus manifester
hier dans les rues de paris et sur les
champs elysées ils protestent à leur
manière contre le 17e mort de rungis une
jeune fille de 18 ans et les motards
continue à réclamer un circuit
carole le foll avait 18 ans elle est
morte
17e victime du circuit infernal de
rungis tous les vendredis soirs ils sont
plusieurs milliers à s'y retrouver tous
fanatiques de la moto paris les excuses
alors ils viennent ici sur une piste qui
n'en est pas une de ligne droite de 600
mètres et 4 virages à angle droit d'un
poids nettement mieux
non seulement un serrurier premièrement
aimé
peut être dangereuse ni aucune
organisation il ya c'est vraiment
l'anarchie
par ce fait même c'est déjà dangereux et
puis aucune protection
tout se mêle aux cuvées frêle mobylette
slalom des manguiers accélérations
rageuses un autre monde fera sans ces
orgies de bruit de vitesse d'ombré de
lumière
ici le danger ne se mesure plus il est
seulement présent mais fugitif quant à
moteur un peu plus inconscients que les
autres ont une gamelle sont les
principaux points qui me semble
dangereux sur ce circuit le risque
d'avoir des tâches de gazole
d'une part et puis les bordures de
trottoirs et les nombreux pylônes sur
sur toutes les trajectoires
personne ne veut plus des motards et les
motards ne veulent plus de rungis
plusieurs solutions ont été avancées
mais tout se trouvent confrontés à des
refus catégorique d'une partie ou de
l'eau on avait parlé de wissous et le
maire adjoint de la commune ne l'entend
pas ainsi
c'est un petit patelin qui a gardé son
côté rural à des deux seuls pays de des
commandes de l'essonne et en définitive
faire passer des milliers de motards et
dans le pays et en plus de ça crée un
circuit à côté sans les invitations et
bien c'est inadmissible doublons qu'on
respecte au moins la tranquillité des
gens qui sont déjà pas mal gêné et par
l' aéroport d'orly et par effectivement
le tout le temps du ce qui passa pas
loin
dans l'imagerie populaire les motards
aux mauvaises réputations trop libre et
rohff ou sans doute les attentions il
commence à s'organiser
les grandes manifestations sur la place
de la concorde le vendredi soir semble
le groupe ait pas de salon de
l'automobile cette année crise de
l'énergie oblige mais cela n'a pas
empêché les constructeurs évidemment de
mettre sur le marché leurs nouveaux
modèles
en cet automne 1977 gérard mérigots en a
profité lui pour créer un petit salon de
l'automobile en plein air il a réuni
dans le parc de saint cloud les
principaux nouveaux modèles il les a
fait défiler comme pour une présentation
de mode voici l'entrée les artistes
puisque le salon n'existait pas il nous
a fallu l'inventer
douze des principales nouveautés de
l'année ont répondu présent à notre
invitation au no 21 s citroën cx gti gs
11130 hélène le premier enfant du couple
peugeot citroën 604 pays
matra simca rancho le tout chemin
démocratique fiat 132 2000 ont dâ
accorde bmv 3,26 et 7,33 porsche 928 et
rover 3005
parmi les plus significatives de ces
nouveautés la renault 21 caisses de la
r30
elle affiche un caractère musclée elle
devrait plaire à ceux qui trouvent la
r30 trop cher et qui ne se satisfont pas
tout à fait de la mollesse de la fin
normale
son moteur de 2 litres fait la
différence
à
en poursuivant la revue de détail de ces
nouveaux modèles un parallèle s'impose
entre la peugeot 604 pays et la citroën
cx 2400 gti
toutes deux sont équipés de moteurs à
injection et de boîte 5 vitesses
tourisme rapides elles sont concurrentes
est issu du même groupe pour sa part bmv
refait ses gammes vers le bas c'est la 3
1 qui évolue toujours la même caisse
compact de porte
ce qui change c'est le moteur il fait
toujours 2000 centimètres cubes mais il
a maintenant six cylindres le plus petit
cylindre du monde
au printemps une version plus étoffée
sera mise sur le marché
reste reste celle qui bouleverse la
logique on les voulait au musée en fait
elle se porte bien
elle consomme beaucoup elles coûtent
très chères elles vont très vite elles
sont ce que l'on peut appeler les
monstres bmv 7,33 elle remplace le haut
de gamme bourgeoise sportive bon genre
porsche 928 la plus chère des douze
voitures présentées elle marque un
virage à 180 degrés dans la technique de
porsche moteur avant huit cylindres en v
refroidissement par eau et si la mode et
anguleuse en matière de forme
porsche lui tourner le dos la 928 est
plutôt ronde plutôt méchant tu es plutôt
à ne pas confier un conducteur moyen
enfin la rover 3005 qu'elle a été élue
voiture de l'année 77 l'industrie
britannique avait bien besoin d'un titre
elle l'a obtenu la rover bien que d'un
prix élevé coûte quand même on peut le
souligner près de 10 millions de
centimes moins chère que la porsche 928
voilà donc si le salon avait eu lieu les
nouveautés que vous auriez pu y
rencontrer à ses douze modèles il
convient d'ajouter que ford opel
mercedes et audi présente également de
nouvelles voitures
nous y reviendrons en tout cas de 18
mille neuf cent soixante francs pour la
ln à cent cinquante six mille francs
pour la porsche 928 qu'il y en a pour
tous les goûts et toutes les bourses
après avoir décidé à l'unanimité
l'annulation du salon de l'auto cette
année les constructeurs français
organise maintenant chacun de leur côté
de mini exposition ils ont peut être
remarqué comme un manque de la part du
public
il se pourrait bien il se pourrait bien
qu'il revienne rapidement sur leur
décision ce ne sera pas et de loin le
moindre paradoxe de l'année automobile
auto moto troisième volet ajoutez à ce
triptyque traditionnelle du week-end un
sport un petit peu moins mécanisée le
jardinage cultivons notre jardin avait
dit à peu près à voltaire depuis des
lustres cela n'est pas tombée dans
l'oreille d'un sourd
je veux parler de ces jardiniers
amateurs qui se livrent à longueur de
week end ou de vacances à leurs passe
temps favori il expose aujourd'hui et
demain au parc floral de vincennes le
fruit de leur travail leurs plus beaux
légumes par exemple
à forrest on quand on est jardinier
amateur et qu'on consacre tous ses
loisirs à son petit carré de légumes à
la gloire de monter un jour à paris pour
recevoir la médaille d'or de la plus
belle tomate ou de la plus grosse pomme
de terre
ce championnat de france des fruits et
légumes qui passe généralement inaperçu
était entouré cette année d'un certain
faste puisqu'il coïncide avec le 150e
anniversaire de la société nationale
d'horticulture plus gros fruits j'éteins
doyenné du comice de 840 g
c'est votre records dont le record c'est
de bélanger linder kg 6 ans quand cette
année non elle a été poussée en 1932
elle chante nos souffrances des sous
bois rue d'alairac à l'endroit où elles
uniprix aujourd'hui les jardiniers
amateurs méprise en général les engrais
les villes ont leur truc
par exemple monsieur désir étape aux
lauréats de l'exposition qui colle de
savigny-sur-orge culte ils ces plantes
grasses dans d autres photos
il a également considérablement
améliorer le confort de ses racines en
utilisant ces pots de fleurs à l'envers
autre truc paraît-il très efficace
l'électro culture l'agriculture consiste
à capter comme les paratonnerres
l'électricité atmosphérique ou par des
pointes ou par des appareils enfouis
dans le sol mais qui comporte également
des points et qu'il communique cette
électricité où ces différences de
potentiel atmosphérique réseau depuis de
faire sur le terrain qui lui-même capte
les tristes et tellurique à condition
d'être orientés sud nord magnétique
ah bon élan qu'est ce que c'est alors à
ce moment-là ça facilite les échanges
jazz hot avec la préfère et c est là la
vie microbienne les plus grands savants
savent pas exactement ce qui se passe
mais en tout cas les résultats sont là
haut
on ne soupçonnait pas les trésors
d'imagination dépensés chaque dimanche
dans les potagers
mais il faut bien avouer que pour faire
progresser la science horticole certains
vont jusqu'à friser la fantaisie la plus
pure des orangers factice mais qui ont
été faits feuille par feuille par nos
adhérents et dans lequel nous avons
inventé de petit citron de manière à
donner cette impression d'oranger comme
autrefois on les arrêts à notre château
de meudon à nos francs gelé du château
d'eau
il est en terre entièrement faux il est
entièrement faux mais reconstitué à
partir de petites feuilles et le petit
chiffon par nos adhérents 3 télégramme
de sport encore en tennis demain dans la
finale du national c'est-à-dire du
championnat de france de tennis françois
jauffret rencontrera patrice dominguez
en sport automobile le pilote français
jean claude andruet au volant d'une fiat
abarth a remporté samedi le 15e rallye
automobile de san remo et puis dans près
de sept minutes maintenant des buts au
parc des princes à paris la rencontre de
football amicale entre l'union
soviétique et la france vous en verrez
d'ailleurs des extraits et des buts s'il
y en a dans la dernière édition du
journal vers 23 heures 13
nous avons commencé ce journal en
parlant de la pluie je vous propose de
terminer ce journal avec de la pluie
encore de la pluie sur new york
le ciel américain en effet n'a pas
participé à la fête pour à un petit
événement dans le monde du show-business
la remise à france gall et à michel
berger d'un disque d'or pour leur
dernier album leur maison de disque
avait bien fait les choses
un voyage à new york beaucoup spectacle
à broadway et une longue promenade dans
les célèbres quartiers de new york
je vous retrouverai avec plaisir pour la
dernière édition du journal et je vous
laisse donc en musique
oui ben may
touchés
pascal à new york sous la pluie
trois guerres
de chacun se met à chanter
que chacun
sa taille
les soca
mais à jouer
m
they came
les filles
m
peut-être avoir ajouté
on est rien
je
la fonte des doigts
k
tous testés ska daisy
musée
bonsoir match nul de l'équipe de france
face à l'union soviétique 0 0 au parc
des princes condamnation unanime de tous
les partis politiques espagnols pour
l'attentât qui a coûté la vie à un
notable basque l'ouverture des assises
nationales du troisième âge à lyon le
lancement d'un pétrolier géant à saint
nazaire
enfin la rubrique que littéraire d'
alain gillot-pétré la fin de ce journal
voici les principaux titres donc de
cette dernière édition et nous
commençons donc par le football à 40
jours de france bulgarie match décisif
pour le voyage en argentine pour la
coupe du monde
la prestation de l'équipe de france ce
soir face à l'union soviétique laisse
quand même quelque peu perplexe surtout
au vu du résultat 0-0 il est peu
flatteur quelques occasions de but quand
même mais il faut bien se souvenir que
les soviétiques sont toujours une équipe
difficile à jouer
voici des extraits de ce match je pense
que nous allons voir dans quelques
instants les extraits de ce match donc
qui s'est terminée et finalement par 0 à
0 quelques occasions de but je voulais
dit voilà je crois qu'on a fait toutes
façons de gros problèmes avec l'ennemi
et aux scop
je pense qu'on pourrait tout de suite
passé par exemple le résultat du
championnat de france de basket ball en
nationale 1 monaco a battu nice 79 à 65
orthez battu bagnolet 94-92 avignon
berck le mans clermont caen qui a battu
2 1 106 à 84 et villeurbanne en battant
antibes sont les autres vainqueurs de
cette journée
deux autre télégramme de sport en corse
et le français bernard darniche qui a
gagné le rallye automobile de san remo
et puis en tennis en finale du national
demain c'est à dire en finale du
championnat de france patrice dominguez
qui a battu patrick proisy rencontrera
françois jauffret rosemary darmon et
gallo verra ont gagné pour la sixième
année consécutive
double dames je pense que jacques
croisés que vous préviendrez lorsque
nous aurons les images du football nous
allons maintenant parler de l'espagne
tous les partis politiques
oui vous en prie voilà l'avertissement
déjà croisé pardon il vient très bien
merci jacques et bien ce résumé du match
urss france le voici les français sont
bien sûr en bleu et on a vu ce soir une
équipe de france commençant très bien sa
partie et puis subissant l'emprise d'une
équipe soviétique toujours très
difficile à manier une équipe soviétique
très forte techniquement très rapide
comme ici sont numéro dix co l'occoq qui
forcerait que plus dure est excellent à
un arrêt difficile les français ont eu
des occasions par michel platini
notamment qui placera 2
heureusement pour lui sur la
transversale il y eu des bons thing
comme ce tir de batna est comme des tirs
de janvion des actions de d'alger comme
ici mais jamais la défense soviétique ne
s'affola jamais la défense soviétique ne
fut réellement danger sauf peut-être
visite en attendant de prendre de michel
platini qui rebondit sur la transversale
le nancéen se prend la tête à deux mains
il était dit qu'il ne marquerait pas
rocheteau entré en deuxième mi temps une
tête magnifique de jean billon est
encore un superbe arrêt du gardien
soviétique qui détourne en corner
nous revoyons sous un autre angle ce
corner de dominique rocheteau qui fut
plébiscité il est bon de le préciser
malgré l'élimination de saint-etienne
par le public du parc et du reste
janvier bathenay sur bien meilleure
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'avait été
quelques jours plus tôt à à manchester
bref rien ne fut marqué dans ce match ce
n'est pourtant pas les occasions qui ont
manqué au onze de france en deuxième
mi-temps les buts ils les ont peut-être
gardé dans un mois contre la bulgare
mais il faut l'espérer je pense que nous
avons aussi les résultats d du
championnat de france de 2e division
thierry roland oui oui mon cher gérard
les voici les résultats dans le groupe a
tout d'abord vous constaterez avec moi
que auxerre est allé gagner à
fontainebleau
c'est un bon résultat victoire également
à l'extérieur de besançon qui gagne à
avignon et beaucoup de buts marqués
haguenau béziers aura lieu demain dans
le groupe b c'est différent il n'y a pas
de victoire à l'extérieur un gros score
de dunkerque face à guingamp tours et
angoulême résultat nul 2 à 2 de même que
poissy et le paris football club brest
et lille toujours sur ce même score de 2
à 2 à noter la victoire de rennes contre
quand ça ne va pas très fort pour les
protégés de mouilleron match important
demain
red star contre boulogne merci thierry
rolland voilà donc pour le sport
l'actualité
les autres titres de l'actualité
maintenant avec l'espagne tout d'abord
tous les partis politiques donc sans
exception ont condamné l'assassinât du
président de l'assemblée de biscaye
monsieur hinse état c'est un nouvel
attentat contre la démocratie distille
les partisans au sommet de la moncloa la
réunion historique du gouvernement et de
l'opposition espagnole ses partisans ses
participants plutôt ont signé un appel
demandant à tous les espagnols de
continuer à avoir confiance en la
démocratie
aucune organisation n'a revendiqué cet
attentat qui a fait trois morts et un
blessé grave mais il est difficile
d'oublier qu'il y a moins de 48 heures
le thé à l'organisation séparatiste
basque a répété qu'il n'était pas
question pour elle de déposer les à
l'assassinât de monsieur winch et avait
été soigneusement préparé letter savait
qu'ils allaient jouer à la pelote basque
avec ses amis tous les samedis matin
ils ont donc attendu à la sortie du
parking et en tirer à coups de
mitraillette sur sa voiture
finalement on peut se demander si cet
attentat commis pour le jour même où
pour la première fois tous les partis
d'opposition rencontrer le gouvernement
de monsieur suarez ne va pas accélérer
la proclamation d'un pacte de salut
national entre toutes les tendances de
la vie politique espagnole à la sortie
de la réunion de montclos à les
socialistes et les communistes ont déjà
qualifié d'ailleurs les travaux de
positif et toujours à propos du pays
basque le militant séparatiste à
palettes et guy a disparu placez le 6
septembre dernier sous contrôle
judiciaire il aurait dû normalement se
présenter vendredi dernier au
commissariat central de marseille
les policiers ne l'ont point vue d'après
ses avocats cette absence n'aurait pas
un caractère définitif la sphère
schleyer france-soir libération est une
agence de presse suisses ont reçu ce
matin une lettre de trois pages ainsi
qu'une photo du patron des patrons ouest
allemand qui est toujours aux mains de
ses ravisseurs depuis près de cinq
semaines maintenant je vais bien dit il
dans cette lettre à son épouse
mais je voudrais bien que le
gouvernement allemand prenne rapidement
une décision monsieur chaban delmas est
rentré lui aujourd'hui d'israël où il
vient d'effectuer un bref séjour privé
jeunes était chargé d'aucune mission at
il dit à son retour mais l'ancien
premier ministre a quand même déclaré
qu'il allait rendre compte au
gouvernement français des entretiens
qu'il a eus avec monsieur des guides de
réunions politiques
aujourd'hui en france le congrès
extraordinaire du cds à lyon dans la
soirée jean lecanuet a été élu président
et andré diligent a été élu nouveau
secrétaire général du centre des
démocrates sociaux
et puis réunion à paris du comité
directeur du parti socialiste un
communiqué sera publié demain en fin de
matinée présentant la position du parti
socialiste après la rupture des
négociations sur l'actualisation du
programme comme ce matin tout court du
journal inattendu de rtl françois
mitterrand avait répété à peu près ces
déclarations d'hier soir dans le journal
de tf1 à savoir il faut éviter que le
pays ne tombe dans une sorte de guerre
civile larvée
tout le monde nous tirent dessus a dit
le leader socialiste et parce que le
parti socialiste en l'espace de six ans
est devenu le premier parti
c'est en ce moment à lyon les
participants aux assises nationales du
troisième âge assiste à une grande
soirée spectacle
mais avant de se distraire la plupart
d'entre eux ont travaillé au cours des
nombreuses réunions qui se sont tenues
aujourd'hui et qui s'achèveront demain
par un grand déjeuner et par le discours
du président de la république
un reportage de patrick da ros de fr3
lyon cette manifestation sans précédent
aurait pu attirer encore plus de monde
puisque vingt mille personnes avaient
souhaité pouvoir exprimer leur point de
vue à lyon faute de suffisamment d'eau
tels cela n'a pas été possible
des personnes du troisième âge qui
souhaite plus que jamais participer à la
vie sociale
bref avoir une retraite active tourner
et pourquoi pas vers l'avenir
c'est en cela que la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui est exemplaire et ce qui
compte c'est surtout de montrer ce qui
se fait de mieux en france visant à
stimuler les autres la participation à
la vie sociale est quelque chose de
nouveau des personnes d'âgés vous savez
en deux grands problèmes celui des
ressources et celui de leur isolement
leur solitude
elles ont réussi à briser cet isolement
cette solitude dans de nombreux endroits
c'est ainsi que les clubs pour personnes
âgées nous en avions mis dans 68 ans
dont la voiture elle ment plus de dix
mille dont la moitié en milieu rural et
2 millions de garçons âgés sont
regroupés par eux alors c'est ce que
nous avons voulu montrer en donnant la
parole au troisième âge 16 tables rondes
accueillait aujourd'hui les participants
avec des thèmes très différents la
culture et les personnes âgées leurs
rapports avec les médias ou encore le
troisième âge utile aux autres
générations et madame pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi ce thème le
troisième âge utile aux autres
générations futures qu'il est vraiment
très intéressant et qui me semble
oui autant fois il n'y avait pas de
différence en tournée entre les parents
les enfants et les jeunes quoi et
maintenant il y avait une coupe alors du
fil de trois heures pour l'impression
bien au contraire un ensemble non quoi
lance une solidarité une solidarité
voilà nous vous rendrons contre demain
soir de la fin de cette journée
nationale du troisième âge à lyon
attentats la nuit dernière contre le
domicile d'alain peyrefitte le ministre
de la justice
pas de victimes quelques dégâts
matériels c'est à dire cet attentat a
été revendiqué par le noyau armée pour
l'autonomie populaire un groupe
d'extrême gauche qui s'était déjà
déclaré l'auteur du meurtre de jean
antoine tramoni le vigile de la régie
renault qui avait tué le jeune pierre
overney et puis arrestation à strasbourg
de quatre jeunes gens qui depuis
quelques jours faisait des cartons sur
les passants les voitures et les
vitrines de la ville
il essayait entre guillemets leurs armes
parait-il la police a découvert chez eux
un véritable arsenal une carabine 22
long rifle avec un silencieux un
pistolet mitrailleur de 9 mm des
pistolets et un stock de 800 cartouches
à saint nazaire ce matin lancement d'un
géant un géant des mers de 414 m
pétrolier frère jumeau du bâti lui c'est
du bella mia
ils ne posent il possède pas moins d'un
hôtel avec ses chambres de plusieurs
restaurants d'une piscine d'une seule
salle de sport et d'un cinéma véritable
ville flottante que nous avons eu bien
du mal à lancer un autre journal de 20
heures mais cette fois jacques merlino
va se jeter à l'eau sans problème pour
le commentaire deux fois plus grand
entre la tour montparnasse 11 fois plus
lourd que la tour eiffel
c'est l'un des plus grands pétroliers du
monde baptisé aujourd'hui à saint
nazaire
ce navire affrété par elf portera le nom
de pierre guillaumat président d'honneur
de elf aquitaine immense réservoir de
648 mille mètres cubes
il est équipé d'une centrale thermique
qui fournira l'énergie nécessaire à la
propulsion et son poste de pilotage est
doté des derniers perfectionnements
technique il assurera à cinq rotations
par an entre le golfe persique et
l'europe transportant à chaque voyage
554 mille tonnes de pétrole brut
mais sera-t-il rentrent sains aux 3 %
d'économies qu'il permettra de réaliser
sur les coûts de transport ses
détracteurs oppose l'énorme
investissement qu'il nécessite à temps
pour sa propre construction que pour
celle du port d'antifer spécialement
conçu pour accueillir ces géants de la
mer à lui seul rappelons le le port
d'antifer avait coûté près d'un milliard
de francs
les écologistes soulignent le risque
fantastique de pollution en cas
d'accident mais ces critiques n'arrête
pas la société elf un second pétroliers
de la même taille sera lancée en juillet
il va bientôt falloir revoir et corriger
l'expression le beurre dans les épinards
les français en effet en mangent de
moins en moins du beurre une diminution
de 3% au cours du premier semestre en
1977 la margarine elle au contraire
c'est bien vendus + 1 % miracle à
lourdes monsieur moreau un ancien mineur
le dit il avait perdu la parole depuis
plus de douze ans au cours d'un
pèlerinage à lourdes le 23 août dernier
il a été frappé par une sorte de boule
de feu qui lui a traversé la poitrine
lorsque je suis retourné à mon hôtel
j'ai recommencé à parler
nous sommes le 8 octobre pourquoi ne
l'avait-il pas dit plus tôt et puis dans
la série bizarre bizarre toujours le
casse-tête du président d'un des
tribunaux de lisbonne la police a arrêté
deux frères jumeaux pour vol à la tire
et violent or il n'ya qu'un coupable
les deux frères jumeaux se ressemblent
tellement que personne pas même les
victimes ne peuvent le reconnaître et
pour tout arranger l'un et l'autre pro
clament leur innocence
bien difficile à résoudre ce cas là la
rubrique littéraire d' alain
gillot-pétré vous n'êtes pas de faire
jouer ou à la non non pas de problème
normalement nous avions rendez vous
jeudi mais pour cause d'actualité nous
avons dû reporter ce rendez vous voir
samedi c'est donc nous allons parler
d'abord du prix goncourt prix goncourt
qui tous les ans est décernée le 21
novembre par la fameuse académie le
troisième lot 19 en troisième ligne
novembre il y à 16 titres encore en
course alors tout simplement je vais
vous poser la question à cent mille
dollars qu'il est votre tiercé savait à
ce jeu de qui perd gagne on gagne très
souvent c'est à dire que l'on perd mais
enfin
en prenant ces risques disons que il
serait étonnant que l'un de ses trois
livres n'est pas le prix goncourt la
vallée des roses de lucien bodard
camille bourniquel tempo et didier
decoin john l'enfer
alors évidemment c'est un tiers si il y
à des outsideurs j'en vois trois
personnellement agustin gomes archos
anna non c'est un auteur espagnol qui
écrit directement en français
l'accès plus difficile à lire que le
présent c'est le nom beaucoup plus
facile les cordes de bois d'antonine
maillet c'est une acadienne qui écrit en
akkadien et un garçon en l'air de didier
martin un romancier qui n'écrit que des
romans
voilà c'est dit trois plus trois égale 6
ce qui ne veut pas dire que l'un des 10
autres romans sélectionnés soient
écartés absolument aucun
heureusement nul encore citer ne coiffe
tous les autres le poteau résultats donc
le 21 novembre pour le goncourt
mais un deuxième sujet de votre vrai que
ce soir c'est jules verne
mais je garde c'est pas nouveau quand
même alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est
nouveau jeu vidéo en fait tout
simplement l'année prochaine on fêtera
le 150e anniversaire de la naissance de
jules verne à nantes où il y aura
d'ailleurs un musée jules verne et
j'ouvre pas l'injure de vous le
présenter
on a vendu plus de 20 millions de ses
livres en france et au moins au moins
autant dans le monde entier en français
en anglais en allemand en russe en grec
en chinois et même en persan mais jules
verne est un moteur d'actualité pourquoi
d'abord parce que son ère est pour la
première fois cette année au programme
de l'agrégation de lettres modernes mais
surtout relisez julien et vous verrez
que ces prophéties sont absolument
confondante anatole france par exemple
reproché à jules verne de dire comment
vous dites qu'on va pouvoir aller sur la
lune évolué aux enfants c'est un
scandale c'est bien on est allé c'est
pas c'est pas extraordinaire mais ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que jules verne
avait décrit la fusée apollo même auteur
même poids même métal peu de choses près
jules verne avait écrit que le module
lunaire décollerait de la lune à tel
endroit pour atterrir dans l'océan à tel
autre endroit et bien apollo xiii est
reparti de la lune du lieu prévu par
jules verne et atterrit dans le
pacifique à quatre kilomètres de
l'endroit indiqué par jules verne dans
de la terre à la lune alors régalez vous
avec les intégrales de jules verne aux
éditions hachette
vous y retrouverez 64 volume toute
l'oeuvre de jules vient toute la vie
romanesque parce qu'il a réussi des
opérettes beaucoup de choses avec des
reproductions de la célèbre éditions
hetzel
et puis moins connus le village aérien
et l'étonnante aventure de la mission
barsacq
ce sont des ouvrages introuvable ce sont
les autres ou wable édité par les mêmes
les humanoïdes associés
vous y retrouverez toute la magie du r
très bien beaucoup de livres de chevet
donc pas terminée journal la météo vous
savez qu'elle est catastrophique en
italie en ce moment il ya eu 11 morts et
plusieurs disparus à la suite des pluies
qui ont provoqué des inondations dans
l'italie du nord
en france cela météo n'est pas très
favorable pour demain le temps sera très
nuageux et pluvieux de la manche
occidentale aux pyrénées au golfe du
lion le soir les pluies vont s'étendre
des ardennes au midi midi
née 1 les vents de sud à sud-ouest se
renforceront notamment sur les côtés
dans la vallée du rhône
je vous retrouverai demain à 13h avec
grand plaisir je vous souhaite une très
belle nuit
parlez à quelqu'un quand la vie devient
invivable
vous savez que cela peut être une
nécessité mais dans ces moments là vous
n'avez pas toujours quelqu'un pour vous
écouter c'est pour cette raison que sos
amitié existent elles seraient amitié
vous nous parler nous vous écoutons
demain dimanche c'est notre programme
commencera à 10h55 avec anne concert
donné par l'orchestré philharmonique de
ville sous la direction de jean claude
casadesus cet orchestre interprétera la
messe en si mineur de jean sébastien
bach à 12h10 ce michel lancelot vous
proposera à son émission toujours
sourire une émission qui sera consacré à
trois espoirs de du rire et à partir de
13h sera diffusée la première édition du
journal de l'aide à 13h25 bien sûr et
tout au long de l'après-midi nous
retrouverons toute l'équipe de bon
dimanche
jacques martin en tête avec tout d'abord
la lorgnette ces messieurs nous disent
il y aura également un nouvel épisode de
la série sur la piste des cheyennes
n'oublions pas les nuggets à 17h25
téléphone appel de rome si vous le
passez la au
allo ciné on déconne oui là lui vaut
lieu aujourd'hui mon vous avez une idée
merveilleuse d'installer votre miroir
parce que les relations téléphoniques
qui sont formidables
j'ai demandé cet appel de la soyez pas
amer roma ces compensations
comment s'est passée la balade à rio sur
un rythme plus animé que nous l'avions
escompté il faudra éviter qui a troqué
le temps vous êtes entier je crois il
devrait oui j'aimerais je vous en
donnerai pendant que j'y pense look de
miley a téléphoné prend une des
prétentions sont jacksonville en janvier
janvier de cette année c'est trop tôt
vous disposez les personnes sur place
c'est vous qu'il veut il y a deux
bouteilles à gaz chaque chose fait un
petit kilo oui l'ouverture là où
vespasien rencontrée l'été trône au 14e
siècle
c'est le code napoléon toujours et
müller vous attend février écouter sinon
j'aimerais autant ne pas le faire le
délai bien trop cher le mieux c'est de
la plaie justement il est à la même
ville que vous vous pourriez peut-être
le persuader le faire appel à quelqu'un
d'autre
d'accord je vous tiens au courant ciao
vous avez déjà compris que toute une
partie de cette conversation était en
code
cela signifie en fait que driscoll
devrait prendre dans les toilettes de
l'hôtel cromwell à londres pour deux
millions de dollars de diamants et d
apporter à un certain ulrich
international j'écoute goutines carach
fonctionne ici valletais hoffman de la
firme strasbourg
est ce que monsieur ullrich et là je
suis désolé monsieur mardi et a géré
l'appel de mon numéro suivant 3 118 29
87 et ma chambre c'est le ses 306 donc à
monsieur
alors cevoli je viens d'une ric les au
courant oui je sais je viens de parler à
ciment et pas l'air très chaud c'est que
le délit cours jour un peu de temps
avant un accord avec elle s'appelle
pourriez gagner du temps et un peu
d'argent on demande à un ciment
quelqu'un sur place et vous a dit le
montant de la chose ouais alors prenez
matisse à sa guise la route vaincu les
vôtres à l'eau les éclats mais fléchit
dit j'accorderai un bonne nuit
ben ça c'est pas le problème désiré au
moins 48 heures si je pouvais les cales
et vous seriez d'accord
affaire conclue